NICOLE STEELE:
So these cops,
caught lying and with
their abusive behavior...
remained on the street?
We own this city.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
The story of We Own This City
is about
the Gun Trace Task Force,
which was probably
one of the most corrupt squads
in policing history in America.
SPEAKER: The actual police work
of protecting a community,
of solving crimes,
had collapsed.
That was already critiqued
in The Wire.
The next moment
in the history of Baltimore
is that officers were actually
just robbing people.
-OFFICER: How much you got here?
-Eleven thousand.
OFFICER 2: (WHISTLES) Wow.
That's the equity from
when I refinanced my house.
"The equity" my ass.
A lot of thought went into,
how do we do this
in the most careful way?
When did you first start
doing robberies?
It wasn't like armed robbery.
Every story in this series
was based on
some real-life, true event.
You can feel that on set.
It gives it a different level
of attention to detail,
a different level
of authenticity.
To see it on screen
is gonna be triggering
for a lot of people.
Get on the wall.
There's always one watching.
D WATKINS: The tradeoff is
it has to be shown
because it's the only way
we'll ever get this reform
that everybody
dreams about.
JON BERNTHAL:
Shooting this in Baltimore,
you can't ask for anything more.
We have to tell this story here,
with these folks,
for these folks,
and by these folks.
(TIRES SCREECHING)
-OFFICER 3: Show me your hands!
-OFFICER 4: Get out of the car!
It happened in Baltimore,
and we're here
walking in their shoes now.
Meeting people
that they affected.
CIVILIAN: Why you pull me over
anyway?
Well, why did we pull him over?
Rear license obscured.
It don't look obscured to me.
But it was quite emotional
to be hearing the stories
from passersby telling us
what it felt like
and what hasn't changed
and what needs to change.
Police yourselves!
REINALDO GREEN:
My father worked for
the Department of Investigation
in New York,
so I have a lot of respect
for a lot of the practices,
but disdain for some
of the institutional things.
And so, I was sort of
always in the middle.
Those nuances, hopefully,
make their way into
the storytelling process
because these are human beings
put in real-life situations.
And what would you do
if you were put
in that situation?
OFFICER 5: I don't know, man.
OFFICER 6:
What you don't know, man?
It's yours, you earned it.
JOSH CHARLES: You have all these
different points of view.
And every point of view
is given some validity.
It's really easy to just
make this guy the bad guy
and these guys
are the good guys.
And on some level,
that is what's happening.
But there's just
more nuance to it.
If you want to do this job,
then you're gonna get complaints
for doing this job.
This story is so relevant
and will remain relevant
until something actually
happens to change that.
JUSTIN FENTON: We're trying
to explore the tension
between trying
to keep the city safe
and doing it
in a constitutional way.
I think we're still trying
to figure that out.
It's not a partisan issue.
If policing's fair,
then it's good for all of us.
♪ (DRAMATIC OUTRO
MUSIC PLAYS) ♪